forget Kim Kardashian Mexico has truly
broken the internet in 2014 with the
hashtag yeah make on say or I'm tired
we're talking eight million tweets in
three months it's been so successful
some say there's even a plot to try and
kill it
yama can say began as a demand for
justice for the 43 students who
disappeared at the hands of police and a
drug gang on September 26 I spoke with
the digital activist Alberto scoria who
runs a site yarmulke AMX and helps
convene the first demonstrations around
the hashtag Alberto says that social
media in Mexico now and in recent years
has amplified protests and made real
change
tenemos UN poder de decidir Delphine our
Ocasio por en cambio cuando cuando
scream los cuando consumers photos con
screamo santa cruz
he says protests have fed off of one
another thanks to live streaming vines
and Instagram cities in town see the
footage and then form their own local
demonstration is the next day but get
this after nearly a month of trending
globally the hashtag llaman can say
suddenly disappeared did people stop
talking about it maybe or did it become
one of those hashtags that's gotten so
popular that it stops trending like
Justin Bieber but the strange thing is
is that according to Albert Aoyama can
say didn't just fall slowly from the top
trending topics it vanished he and other
organizers have a theory they think the
Mexican government had a hand in the
hashtags disappearance by using
automated spambots technique
accommodating artists permanently in
topic but otra vez the millions of
quilters how does it work location is
upon their body as message at hashtag
veteran tweet no opponent unless the
pornography opponent photo scanner
correspondent photos Melendez in Tony
Manero automatica Twitter and annalisa
use hashtags Alvarez dos comportamiento
x' por los consider a spam yes sir no
solamente una cuenta SEMA millas de
Quinta's poster mina consider ando Tolo
the mass the hashtag is to come up on
yesterday's open equality opposition
clever alberto even created a map of the
tweets using a piece of software called
defi and saw that bot tweets have a
specific shape and form that isn't
normal to regular Twitter conversation
regular Twitter users respond to one
another and retweet you can spot BOTS
because their tweets don't communicate
with one another crazy huh the doses
Connaughton assessed equipo de
millersofoz
que que sabe que los Piratas Alicante NS
a capacitor the cordon I don't know
Paris wanna see go local or else kinda
hit the nos a connected can a protester
you can hasta más de condorcet important
in response to what they believe is an
attack Twitter's have been adding
numbers after the hashtag yum I can say
2 3 4 and so on when those hashtags get
spammed they move on to the next number
it's gotten up to llaman can say 15 and
Counting each with tens of thousands of
tweets if it was the Mexican government
who messed with the hashtag it's not a
bad idea the country's recent history is
full of online activism that sparked
social movements back in 2009 the
hashtag internet necesaria or necessary
internet successfully stopped a new tax
on web use and phone services and in
2012 a student movement
swelled in opposition to Pena Nieto's
candidacy that was known as yosoy132 it
was an online response to the mainstream
media's portrayal of the student
protesters as trained infiltrators the
yosoy132 movements spread like wildfire
across mexico's universities caseta
Rodriguez from the Electronic Frontier
Foundation told us why hashtags like
yarmulke say are so important there's a
high number of journalists who are
disappearing in Mexico and even clearer
people who try to deny himself even been
killed for reporting about a narco
traffic more politics that are in Mexico
and as Alberto put it through social
media and a unified hashtag Mexicans are
telling the world about their country's
other reality that neither the governor
Norman stream media is talking about the
drug corruption and state repression and
most importantly people taking action
pretty inspiring stuff